يُعرف هذا المسجد ذو اللون الأزرق
بأنه واحة للسلام ،
فهو يحول الحمائم المحيطة به إلى
مزار شريف أبيض نقي
أو مسجد أزرق يقع في
شمال أفغانستان وهو قطعة صغيرة
من الهدوء داخل منطقة حضرية صاخبة
عند دخولك  الحديقة
يذوب ضغوط المدينة ويحل محله
الأذان السلمي للصلاة
وهديل الحمام يتميز المسجد بالعديد من الميزات
بالإضافة إلى مظهره الخارجي المذهل ،
يوجد قن للحمامات حيث يتم
إطعام الطيور وتربيتهم يعود تاريخه إلى القرن الثاني عشر.
القرن وضريح حضرة علي الذي
كان ابن عم النبي محمد وصهره ،
لا يمكن دخول الضريح إلا من
قبل المؤمنين
[موسيقى
] ، وتتكون الألوان الزرقاء المبهرة التي تغطي
المسجد من تفاصيل عالية
وموضوعة بشكل معقد
يتم استبدال البلاط باستمرار بسبب
التجوية وغالبًا ما يتخذها
الزوار كتذكارات دينية على الرغم من
أن المدينة قد شيدت حول
الضريح ، إلا أن هدوء المسجد الأزرق
لا يزال هادئًا.  xcept للمكالمات اليومية
للصلاة
[موسيقى]